a thirteen-year-old student is in
critical condition this morning after a
classmate started shooting at an Indiana
middle school on Friday a teacher is
being called a hero after he was wounded
while tackling the gunman the school is
in Noblesville north of Indianapolis
Adriana Diaz reports a terrifying
situation it's become a routine sight a
math student
Exodus this time at Noblesville West
middle school after explosions of
gunfire pierced the halls the shooting
was right next to us we were all really
scared all my friends ran to the corner
for safety Police Chief Kevin Joe wood a
male student asked to be excused from
his class he left the classroom he then
returned armed with two handguns shortly
after 9:00 a.m. a student gunman fired
at least four shots in his seventh grade
science class students say that's when
their teacher 30 year-old Jason seaman
tackled the shooter and managed to swap
the gun out of his hands we were all
just screaming oh my god
Sammy Lovell was in the classroom his
eyes were very he looked just upset and
very angry but I don't think anyone
knows why this is the 17th school
shooting this year the 4th this month
last Friday 10 people were killed by a
17 year old student at Santa Fe High
School in Texas back in Indiana the
alleged shooter is being held in police
custody while the teacher and student
Ella Whistler are hospitalized with
gunshot wounds semen was shot three
times in the stomach hip and arm the
former college football player who
doubles as the middle school football
coach is being hailed as a hero for
putting himself between his students and
the bullets Karen canter Reyes is a
seventh grader what do you think about
the sacrifice mr. Seamon made
like yeah I have no words for it because
it was such an amazing act of caring
police haven't released a motive after
the incident the middle schoolers were
bused from here to the high school and
there they were put on lockdown again
because the high school received threats
as for the hospitalized science teacher
in a statement he thanked his students
for their support and said quote you're
the reason that I teach for CBS this
morning Saturday Adriana Diaz
Noblesville Indiana